foreign
[Music]
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
take a deep dive into some fountains and
I'm going to show you why there's more
of them than we thought there were but
before we dive in I want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission okay so when we talk about
fountains in the POI World we're talking
about usually one of two things the
first is when we take a waist strap that
is turning back and forth between a
forwards and a reverse weave we can move
our hands up and down as we're
performing that waist strap and it
essentially turns the waist strap into a
flower now the other option is What's
called the four beat Fountain and this
involves taking the top part that is
this right here of the waist strap off
entirely and replacing it with something
that looks a lot like a windmill so we
wind up with a trick that looks
something like this Nick Woolsey was
quite the proponent of using this and I
personally think that it looks pretty
cool too and of course a couple years
ago I took on the challenge of figuring
out how to take that floor beat Fountain
into the anti-spin world this follows
all the same rules and conventions as
that in spin version of the four beat
Fountain but it happens to take the
hands around in the opposite direction
that the POI are going in but
that is not actually the end of the
story turns out these two versions of
the four beat Fountain are not the only
versions out there there is an entire
other way to do it in both inspin and
anti-spin so let me take you through how
so to understand how this works let's
dissect our four beat Fountain here
normally when we perform our waist strap
we're doing a total of six downbeats
with each POI if you count the number of
downbeats that the orange POI is doing I
have one two three four five six as I go
all the way around which isn't
surprising because a waist strap is
based on the three beat weave we're
performing a three beat weave reverse
and a three beat weave forwards so of
course we get a total of six beats with
each POI so how exactly do we get down
to doing only four beats well basically
we remove one of these weaves so for
example when I'm going from my reverse
side here to my forward side instead of
Performing that as a standard waist
strap and giving myself those three
beats that come with making that turn I
can instead remove that weave and add a
windmill instead of course as I'm doing
that windmill I'm only performing one
beat with each POI one left one right
before I go back into the waist strap
and so we have one two three four beats
one two three four beats with each
individual hand I'm counting off the
right hand poised beats here so orange
goes once twice three times four once
twice three times four as it goes around
and of course the anti-spin version is
the same idea but the hands go the
opposite direction yeah we still have
one two three beats one up top one two
three beats one up top one two three
beats and one up top thus we get in four
beats going each way cool so both the
inspin and the anti-spin have something
in common namely we've decided decided
that we're taking our waist trap going
in One Direction and replacing it with a
two beat move that goes through it our
windmills right now here's the thing
we're always making the choice to remove
the three beats when we're going from
reverse to forwards What If instead we
removed the three beats when going from
forwards to reverse okay so if I go from
reverse to forwards over here I now have
to come up with a two beat move that I
can do instead of that waist strap back
over to the reverse side so what can I
do well I'm now in a position where my
left hand is on top of my right so going
into a windmill would be a pretty
sketchy proposition but what if instead
I went down that is what if I performed
what we call a water mill instead of a
windmill so all together that winds up
bang I do that waist strap one two three
beats over top and then one beat going
through the water mill again I do one
two three beats and four one two three
beats and four as I'm going around here
it's the same idea as the four beat
fountain that takes us up and around
through the windmill we just happen to
be shifting which side of that waist
strap we're taking away and replacing
with a simple reel so let me show you
that again in slow motion
[Music]
thank you
so you might have noticed that my new
four beat Fountain is also in in spin so
is there an anti-spin equivalent to it
oh you know there is so this one gets a
little bit sketchier but stick with me
here as I'm going up and over and then
dropping into the water mill in in spin
I'm doing right hand leads then left
hand
right hand leads then left hand if I
want to do this anti-spin I have to
reverse this left leads then right left
leads then right so I wind up
with a four beat fountain
that now has the left leading across the
bottom in a water mill pretty cool right
and again let me show you that in slow
motion
[Music]
thank you
sweet so we now have four variations on
the four beat Fountain which I think is
pretty cool because quite frankly back
in the day I didn't even know that there
were two variations on the four beat
Fountain so that's exciting and you know
it just goes to show you no matter how
much we think that we have covered the
depths of all the classical Point moves
there's usually something there that we
somehow missed the first time around so
I hope this inspires some of y'all out
there to go dig through some of those
moves that you first learned as a POI
spinner and see what other new depths
there might be to pull out of them
[Music]
foreign
hey did you get anything out of this
video please leave me a like comment
share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going to help people find
this video and to help my channel grow
thanks in advance and speaking of thanks
this video would not be possible were it
not for the kind support of all of these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter and you would like to become
one you can do so by heading on over to
patreon.com directs factorpoi and
signing up there you can get access to a
whole host of awesome rewards and even
better you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out more videos on
POI Theory like this one I will go ahead
and leave a link to a playlist full of
such videos down in the description or
up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you like this top video
based upon your past viewing habits so
maybe give that a look-see too thank you
so much for watching have yourselves a
good one and more than anything else
make sure to get outside and flow today
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace